ALEXIS MOUSSINE POUCHKINE:
Hello, everyone.
We're here at Devoxx 2014.
And I'm here with Mandy.
Hello, Mandy.
MANDY WAITE: Hey, Alexis.
How are you doing?
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
And we're
here to talk about something I'm
very excited about personally.
I think Mandy, you are as well.
Which is Firebase as a
solution for backends
for a lot of things,
but mobile apps
is probably a pretty
good sweet spot.
Firebase is this company which
has joined the Google Cloud
family recently and
which offers a-- I don't
know if you can call it a
mobile backend as a service.
But something where basically
you have a lot of features
that people are looking for when
they're building mobile apps,
or web apps actually,
without touching the backend,
without spending time
on infrastructure.
Is that a fair assessment?
MANDY WAITE: Yeah,
I think whenever
we're talking about Firebase,
we tend to always circle back
to mobile as being the priority
and the most interesting place
where we can use Firebase today.
Certainly we can do web
applications as well with it.
But, yeah, mobile is
definitely the sweet spot.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE
POUCHKINE: Right.
So talking about
mobile applications,
we're trying to
address a space where
we need to have massive
scale in the backend.
And as a mobile developer,
you spend enough time
writing your mobile app.
And life's too short
to write a backend.
And you probably
don't want to get
into all the nitty-gritty
details of putting together
an architecture and
an infrastructure
to support that back end.
So how does Firebase address
maybe real-time communication?
Because that's typically
what you want in mobile apps.
What are the key features
that Firebase has to offer?
MANDY WAITE: So I think
the guys from Firebase
would refer to their product
as a real-time application
platform.
It effectively allows client
devices, application clients
running on web or running
on mobile to effectively
communicate and share data with
the Firebase servers running
the backend, to provide
authentication services
as well.
But also, most
importantly, to be
able to share data between
other connected devices as well.
It could also be that the
user can access that state
from one device to another.
But most importantly,
that sweet spot, again,
is where data that's
stored from one device
will be pushed out to
the Firebase servers
and then pushed out to any
other interested clients
in real time.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
So can you
say more about real time?
Real time means different
things to different people.
MANDY WAITE: Yeah, so, I
had this kind of problem
as well when I first got
introduced to Firebase.
What does real time mean?
Because I come from a
background where real time would
mean stock tickers,
that kind of thing
where we need to have
things really quickly.
So effectively it's data
being shared and pushed
out to other devices
in milliseconds,
but also without any kind of
requirement in the client side
to actually go and get the data.
So the data will
become available,
will be updated on
the Firebase servers,
and will be
instantaneously pushed out
to all of the other devices that
are interested in that data.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE
POUCHKINE: Right.
So typically when
you talk about data,
it's payloads of JSON
data that's being sent,
notifications go out.
On the client side
how does it work?
Do I register callbacks?
Do I just get notifications
for free when I use the client
library offered by Firebase, ,
again to build an Android app?
How does it work?
MANDY WAITE: Well, yeah,
so it's very simple
to get a connection
to Firebase servers.
We have various different
ways of doing it.
In JavaScript, it's a
fairly simple declaration,
same with Android.
Once you have a reference
to the Firebase servers,
you can very simply make
calls to that reference.
And effectively what you're
doing behind the scenes
is making a RESTful call
to the Firebase servers.
Fully authenticated,
everything controlled.
ALEXIS
MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: So one
of the challenges
in the mobile world
is that connections
are unreliable.
And certainly here where
a number of the speakers
are not in their
home country, they
might or might not have roaming.
And certainly they cannot
rely on Wi-Fi, for example.
MANDY WAITE: Yeah, definitely.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
So that's
one of the many use cases
where that's how life is.
You don't have connectivity
100% of the time.
So does Firebase have
anything to help with that?
MANDY WAITE: Yeah, so this is
one of the real challenges.
Effectively with Firebase having
their own servers and client
devices running applications,
we can get ourselves
into a situation where we
have distributed state.
A state that is
available in clients
but has not been synchronized
with the servers.
And a state that's
on the servers that's
not been synchronized
with all of the clients.
So effectively, we have this
distributed state problem.
Firebase handles
that effectively
by storing data locally.
So whenever you make
a change to data,
it's pushed out
to locally store.
And the application-- event
handlers are fired as required.
And the application can
carry on doing what it does.
And at any point, it would
just connect to that point.
At any point in the future
when we become connected back
to the Firebase
servers, that data
can be synchronized and
pushed back out again.
At that time, all other
interested clients
would also get updates.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: So
we talked about web or Android
in the case of mobile,
but Firebase is really
a solution that spans across
a number of technologies.
So just for the web, I was
looking at the website.
And there a lot of SDKs
and [? findings-- ?]
or I don't know
how you call this--
for all of the popular
JavaScript frameworks
out there, so Angular,
Ember and a few others.
MANDY WAITE: And
Polymer as well.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE
POUCHKINE: Polymer
as well, which is the newer one.
It supports iOS as well.
So there's an Objective-C
client library.
MANDY WAITE: Yeah, so there's
an Objective-C client library.
You have support for iOS,
for Windows, for JavaScript
effectively.
Java support's
really-- by virtue
of being available
on the Android.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Can
you use this at the REST API?
You mentioned there
was a REST API that--
MANDY WAITE: Yeah, so
effectively every single bit
of data that you
store in Firebase
can effectively be
accessed via a URL.
So you can access your data
sets completely via a URL.
Or you can access
individual bits of data
by URLs as well in a
completely RESTful way.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: OK.
So you also mentioned user
management and authentication.
How does that work?
Does it support only
Google Gmail accounts or--
MANDY WAITE: No.
That's a great thing.
So it doesn't just
support Google,
which would've been
a concern, I think.
It supports email and password.
So you can set up very
basic email and password
if you choose to.
It supports out of the box
four authentication providers.
It supports Twitter, GitHub,
Facebook, and Google.
And if you have
another requirement,
maybe to attach to your own LDAP
servers or active directory.
You can effectively roll your
own and use custom auth tokens
to connect to those
authentication providers.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE
POUCHKINE: Great.
So I have to say
it again, I'm very
excited about this Firebase
joining the Cloud platform.
What can we expect from that
fairly recent acquisition
from Google in
terms of integrating
as part of the bigger family?
So I understand the
Firebase [INAUDIBLE] brand
will stick around.
Any integration
that we can share?
MANDY WAITE: Well,
I think one thing
that the guys from Firebase did
announce last week at Google
Cloud Platform Live was
the advent of triggers.
And triggers will
be used effectively
to fire off events
whenever data is touched
or updated, which could allow
us to-- it's effectively
a call to a Webhook.
And a Webhook could be an
App Engine application.
It could be a virtual machine
running on Google Compute
Engine.
It could be running
somewhere else completely,
not on Google Cloud
Platform at all.
Effectively just a
call to a Webhook.
So I think that's
really exciting.
That will effectively
allow us to be
able to have hooks into
Firebase whenever data changes
and invoke functionality
outside of Firebase.
That's the first step
that I'm aware of.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
It's probably also worth
mentioning that we're
not requiring people now
to use the Google
Cloud Platform just
to use Firebase as
they were before.
MANDY WAITE: Yeah, and I'm
hoping that stays that way.
At the moment, you just
sign up for Firebase.
It's got a free
plan, a free tier.
It's got a very simple tutorial.
It's so remarkably easy to
get up and running with it.
It's quite surprising.
You can be expecting to be
asked for your credit card,
but it's pretty straightforward.
Get in there, get
playing with it,
and get started very quickly.
It also has its
own debugging tool
called Forge, which allows
you to [? see the updates ?]
to your data in real time.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE
POUCHKINE: Right.
And I've heard good things
about the documentation.
So I guess it's all good.
So, guys, if you haven't
checked out Firebase already,
I would encourage you to do so.
Whether you're building
web applications,
mobile applications, I
think it's certainly worth
checking out.
So thank you, Mandy.
MANDY WAITE: Thank you, Alexis.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE POUCHKINE:
That's all the time we have.
For further information,
go to firebase.com,
for the time being at least.
And check out
Mandy's session here
at Devoxx, which will be
available on [INAUDIBLE].
MANDY WAITE:
[INAUDIBLE] Thank you.
Cheers.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE
POUCHKINE: Bye bye.
MANDY WAITE: Bye-bye.